hope we're out there in the cold too
long folks
look uh
i invited uh we're different parties but
two good friends down here
we've done an awful lot of supreme court
justice together senator grassley and i
as well as senator durbin and we've
worked together in a lot of court
nominations overall but particularly
supreme court nominees and
selecting the justice is one of the
president's most
serious responsibilities and
as i always said i went back and looked
at a lot of the opening statements i
made apparently
big guy because out of a more supreme
court justice anybody around is still in
congress or associated with government
which is kind of means
we must be beyond 60 chuck i'm not sure
what it is but
for me it'd be 15 or 60. yeah
and i i started way back early on in the
early 70s anyway
um
what uh what we're gonna do is i've said
before and i went back and looked at
some of the
opening statements i made from justice
over the years that you know
the constitution says advise and consent
advice and consent
and i'm serious when i say it that i
want the advice of the senate as well as
the consent we can arrive on who the
nominee should be
and uh you know uh it's uh
there's always a renewed national debate
every time we nominate any president
that nominates a justice
because the constitution has always
involved me slightly
in terms of
additional rights or curtailing rights
etc and it's always an issue
and
several schools of fraud in terms of
judicial philosophy
and uh we'll see but uh the fact is that
i'm looking for
someone who uh
i can uh this is not a static issue it
flows back and forth
and i'm looking for is a candidate with
character with the qualities
of
a judge in terms of being
courteous to the folks before them and
treating people with respect
as well as a judicial philosophy that
is more one that suggests that
there are underneath rights to the
constitution
and uh all the amendments mean something
including the ninth amendment
and uh but i intend to take this
decision
make this decision and get it to my
colleagues
by uh by the end of the month that's my
hope
uh and uh and i'm looking forward to
their advice and how to proceed and how
the hearings will be
conducted and the like so
thank you very much we're going to get a
chance to talk i want to hear from them
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]